was war das dümmste was sie hier ja
leute jetzt bekommen sie ein video vom
kanal und herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten interview auf einem kanal ich
habe vor einiger zeit schon mal
interview auf einem kanal hochgeladen
das war damals hilft wieder stellen und
dieses video ist geisteskranken ganzheit
ist glaube ich über eine million aufrufe
und heute habe ich eine neue
interviewpartnerin die bei kras schule
mitgespielt hat
leute eine runde applaus ist sozusagen
mein linienrichter bei consol de ski und
die recht hast du mal ne leute ihr habt
mir auf instagram einige fragen für wen
ist jetzt wichtig meint ich meine macht
kann sich das ok also nochmal heute das
ist mein ding heißt liegt bei kras
schule eben eine rolle ok und ihr habt
maylin einige fallen auf den boden
gestellt die ich die heute stellen werde
und über einen gucken wie das so war für
dich bei kras studium zu spielen okay
die erste frage kommen von unix lola wie
bist du darauf gekommen bei solchen
reality soaps mitzuspielen
ein fachleute gesucht haben und jetzt
kann basel gearbeitet so führte ein
smartbook sondern werdet die show okay
aber also die überlegung so dass du so
schauspielerinnen oder als
schauspielerin arbeiten willst das war
mir irgendwann oder hast du so die eu
möchte zeitungsannoncen gelesen darüber
dass leute darstellerin nebenjobs neben
der hunde gesucht und das hat super
flexibel und dienstag wesentlich mehr
info t shirts vaters was ich auch
gemacht aber das ist ein in die kuhle
hat spaß gemacht
ok also irgend bekannt und so einen tipp
bekommen habe wirklich oder einfach zum
gerne filme hate statisten luft land und
darf mich einfach gesagt kann es richtig
die zkb fragt ist der job sowie sowie
die in der vorgestellt das also was ich
so etwas ist anders als das ist schon
richtig auch wenn du jemanden zwei
kameras muss und also denkt ist ungefähr
eine kamera ist die ich eine antwort
jetzt mit zunge jetzt aber das ist eine
richtige küche im film oder herzen ist
und das wollte das war auch für rtl2
auch diese ja begeht also dann man sich
sofort stellen ihr seid so so
beieinander und dann so eine riesige
kappe und natürlich die touren der turm
dann hätte sich das ganze anguckt und
dann sagt was besser zu machen und dann
schreibt man jetzt mit zunge ja
mindestens so was wir jetzt machen mit
ok also der job ist anders als wir den
bankrott unterstrich 3x fragt sind
manche szenen unangenehm zu drehen
außerdem ihr auch schon werther effekt
das ist unangenehm
alles wo du tun musst ist wer ist halt
super verliebt und jemanden halt alles
was so solchen tag hat ist lange schon
nicht identifizierte mann aus als
irgendwann hat es halt statt sich nicht
mehr also wenn du quasi so verliebt hat
es ist vor allem verliebt wird als auch
so wenn du glück oder wut so tauschte -
es gern hätte das war einfach ist es
herzlich verliebtheit noch so sehr
unangenehmes intimes also bist du gar
nicht wirklich verlieben die leute ja
hallo hallo kantor iana fragt wie ist
das verhältnis zu deinen kollegen mega
dadurch systems sagen dass mir ja er ist
seinem liebenswerten gedreht ja wir sind
halt alle sind jungen alle sind gleich
alt nur wenig klassenfahrt also wirklich
alle sind miteinander befreundet egal ob
du kompass oder ob darstellerin
darsteller oder ist man auch die freunde
mit dem regisseur der ein schwert dass
man mit ja
liga sind alles ein liebenswert und ich
kann auch kein schlechtes wort sei also
alle am set ist super cool machen auch
immer noch was miteinander obwohl jetzt
ich habe zum beispiel das ok also du
willst immer noch mit den den
schauspielern von
mit einem knappen ja okay gut also
lustig das ist eine frage von
unterstrich marieke unterstrich gibt es
krass schule darsteller beziehungen also
ich musste sich sagen wenn du jetzt
selbstvertrauen müssen aber ich bin
nicht davon betroffen
ich meine so wie damals gibt es noch
gibt es also es ist ich wäre halt gibt
es ich glaube es liegt auch daran dass
jetzt wieder auf der arbeit mit dem
zusammen sich da sowieso weit über
arbeitskollegen auf die nächste frage
könnte auch ganz interessant seien lila
oder strichen die dinger lina
unterstrich mdl fragt wirst du wegen der
rolle gemobbt oder wurdest du brichst
mir das schon leben was erzählt dazu ja
man kann
wer wissen möchte weil ich verträge hast
also ich kann dort wird ist eigentlich
sehr gehofft bei instagram und auch bei
facebook und so weil viele leute ich
glaube diese dann einfach zu ernst
nehmen nicht dampf aus dem dass ich halt
nicht dass sie gas und rechtsanwalt aus
berlin kommen also ich bekomme
wundervolle nachrichten von wegen wer
hier schimpfworte einsatz nicht alles
das wird sich aber wenn du die leute nur
anschreibt und den nahverkehr ist
eigenständig eingestreut rolle
man denkt es so wow du wirst gehälter
ist weil du ja in der folge auf sich
letztes jahr geht übrigens auf 7
millionen autos voll kraft neu in diese
klasse kostet kraft und dann mit einem
typen da war fast jeder andere mit der
anderen sehen wollten gleichzeitig das
war halt wäre so dass kaum verheimlichen
der sendung gewesen und ich komme halt
aber halt auch als person die das nicht
weiß in douglas und dann verlieren wir
uns ineinander
und dafür wird gehasst dass sich die
menschen auseinander gebracht haben wir
eigentlich nicht zusammen machen aber
die halt lieber besser passen
deswegen bin ich die blöde ding ja okay
dann kommen diese so krass schule
verließ boys und girls also die ultra
wichtiger ist wirklich leute also denkt
man gar nicht mehr
wir sind ja beide schon erwachsenen
schon länger aber es ist kann es gibt
wirklich leute die nicht nur nicht sagen
hey was ist das für eine seltsame selbst
am besten wasser oder sogar lustig hin
sondern sich jetzt ernsthaft anschauen
und es dann so ernst nehmen das wirklich
so sein wenn da was nicht richtig oder
richtig als würde die welt
zusammenbrechen weil das pärchen in
dieser sendung vorkommt und dann bin ich
das wie eine hexenjagd
die waren wirklich an so dann doch
einfach zuhause ich sofort meinen job
ist gewissen weil ich jetzt denke heute
bringen wir sehr auseinander also gar
nicht noch mal lena unterstrich
entsprechend leute auf die rolle haben
wenn sie dich sehen
ja aber ich habe das nicht gegangen
du bist doch jessica neun neuen fällen
habe ich gesagt ich bin ich nicht
umgegangen und einmal das war welches da
habe ich nur zugesehen und darf nicht
eine ganze schulklasse angepasst und du
hast den film schon gesehen dass sie
sich gestritten haben er ist ansprechbar
und habe ich das auch zu gehen habe ich
auch noch mit so einem bleistift auf dem
college mit meinem namen drauf
geschrieben aber weil ich das was man
sonst eigentlich nicht entgehen legende
digger geil
das ist günstiger machen also jetzt noch
nicht so dass ich so probleme und da bis
zum mega oft erkannt widerlichkeit aber
wenn so ein lehrer sagen nein bin ich
mit den zusätzlich so die leute kommen
wir das öfter so anderen sagen hey bist
du nicht bist du nicht jessica oder bist
du nicht erst gehen oder so die nichts
wissen provokant gestellt aber ich
glaube muss sich keiner sorgen machen
hannah hdr frage hast du einen abschluss
abitur und du machst jetzt gerade seinen
master master also hast du schon besser
ich habe meine mannschaft ja sogar 28
wir stehen nicht bestätigt mist sawija
punkt erst gab es eine szene die du
nicht drehen wollte ist aber musste
danach denken kannst du doch im erzählen
darüber nachzudenken oder mit meinem
darsteller mit dem ich dann verliebt bin
in der badewanne drehen also nicht wie
man also so war jetzt nicht nackt oder
eher nicht aber ist es doch was wenn du
mit jemandem du eigentlich kaum kennst
in der badewanne
ja ok so soll man das heutzutage kathrin
unterstrichen reinbek wissen
schauspielerin werden oder ist das nur
übergangsweise zum beispiel zum
geldverdienen genau das richtige
grundschülern werden
das macht spaß und es ist wie gesagt ein
cooler als tierschutz halten für mich
aber ich also angenommen ist bietet sich
da irgendwie so ein weg an dass du das
schauspielerinnen werden kann
außerdem wurde anklingen sagen mitredet
mit kenneth wittstock steht noch mal auf
über den handrücken mehr fleiß aber ich
bin nicht schauspielerin aber mit sehr
geehrte war okay okay aber mit marvin
nicht okay hier noch eine frage die es
auch ein bisschen provokanter gestellt
von juwi was war das dümmste was ja
bei 40 grad im schatten als
riesenkaninchen anders dort verkleidet
durch einen club laufen das war der
dämmerung leute das war soweit das
interview mit merlin weil in vielen dank
für ihre frage zum abschluss noch ein
bisschen heftig aber soweit heute ich
habe hier für euch einen vorstandes
video verlinkt finanzwissen schon und
bis zum nächsten mal